I lost my parents in childhood alone no
one understood and spent years brooding
as a nameless your
but through the inspiring words of my
father I'll become a simple and icon the
savior jurist or hope to those who
heaven oh you mean like Batman I travel
the world as a bearded al cats discover
who I bet her does happen though speak
to me in exposition and features of my
life story I will tell it to outer
border and destroying player don't often
have flashbacks out of nowhere about how
important my destiny dark
didn't know when
I'm blowing Kate my liquid shop at the
safe side I have a wise father figure
who isn't my father at all
not my boss
and set for be I'm going to leave the
quest and psychologically tortured not
special I've stared into the past and d4
did have come out scar yet responsibly
strong say I was like when I'm in my
giant dark empty for gels failure I try
to save people but under my protection
is a million
tourists travel on an awkward no you're
not you're an emo huh every woman wants
the sweet one okay you're right about
that over here I have a plan but
independent girlfriend I still have to
save most of the time like mine listen
you can't be Who I am you're a speedy
pretty boy on the freakin vamper the
dark brooding loner is my thing you see
attack spider sure ain't gonna take that
from me
super
Jesus guy what he was gonna he was gonna
kill some random people I didn't know
dude I didn't even kill the insane clown
who murdered my girlfriend oh you're
sick no Superman movie two of the most
polar opposite secret
oh fuck you Zack Snyder
they can be a great people they wish to
be
they only lack the light to show the way
for this reason above all their capacity
for good
I've sent them you my only son
Man of Steel socks man of Steel is
freaking awesome and you know it yeah
maybe for blue hungry Psychopaths but
for those of us who love an American
icon it's bullshit this is a new kind of
Superman Critic he's obviously not the
one we grew up with kept that lemay
sense what time-traveling flying around
the world mostly made some use just
can't accept the fact that this is
something new and well we all know that
the first two films are legendary it's
time for a different way of looking at
this story that's been told a thousand
times the same way okay
look I'm sick to death of that bullshit
argument so I'll tell you what I am
willing to look at this in a new light
because hey we should be willing to
accept things from a new point of view I
will still try my best to accept this as
its own unique thing without drawing any
references from the original movies deal
deal but you have to acknowledge that
when a moment sucks it fucking sucks no
matter how much testosterone-filled
bullshit is in it I make no promises Joe
alright fine well let's look at the
movie that has the internet Oh delete
split down the middle this is either the
absolutely loved or absolutely hated Man
of Steel we start off with the birth of
our hero on Planet every sci-fi movie
ever made and seeing how this is a Zack
Snyder film everything obviously either
looks like HR Geiger's hand-me-downs or
penises look at these things tell me
that doesn't look like the Little
Mermaid poster I actually quite like the
New Krypton look slide five medieval
mesh interesting wildlife but I suppose
the floating robots do look a bit like
the hair doing The Last Airbender oh no
no we have interpretations of that in
barbwire as our High Council is wearing
what I assume is Krypton's version of
mini roller coasters
she's seriously suggesting that we
evacuate the entire planet Oh everybody
here is already dead a lot of you know
the drill here Superman's father jor-el
played by Russell Crowe is trying to
convince the higher-ups that the planet
Krypton is about to explode and nobody
believes him ba tell the entire world
lowing up isn't exciting enough let's
throw in the hostile takeover while
we're at it to this particular hostile
takeover is led by General Zod played by
Michael why does everyone say I Lisp
like Willem Dafoe Shannon these
lawmakers with their endless debates
have let trip down the road help me save
our race that the generated bloodlines
that led us to this state and who will
decide which bloodlines survives on you
I humbly accept your nomination
don't be so seeing how Zod's army fought
off this world equivalent of White House
security so easily it only makes sense
that jor-el should be able to fight off
the odds army that broke through this
world equivalent of White House security
so easily I think he rides on his dragon
fly dragon picked up yet another subplot
because Lord knows we don't have enough
of those going on this opening and plans
to put it in a space pod sending his son
to earth who will be the only survivor
my lesson now shoot we gotta have that
pesky emotion come on this is a
Christopher Nolan story you can throw in
more subplots at least wrap that baby to
a bomb or something
he rises from the dentist Jaron is sent
out towards birth
just before Zod's forces arrive
concentrate fire on the main door your
ass person who clearly has no microphone
attached to his mouth what have you done
we've had a child's on Harris this one
stuff a bag of marshmallows his mouth
before talking yes just good our friend
must clear lab actually the funny thing
about Michael Shanna's performance is
how he manages to be both over-the-top
extreme and under the bottom restraint
it's kind of like watching Jerry Lewis
act he may start off low and appear not
to be very interested but then in a
millisecond he can change into what hey
what's that streaming and I yell and and
the nice lady oh shut up he did great
Michael Shannon is a damn good actor he
was portraying a bitter single-minded
man who has nothing to lose
as he's pushed to the breaking point
yeah but does this breaking point have
to sound like a bulldog you won't tell
us
oh yeah well at least it isn't selling a
screaming goat when he yells hey I do
not
bearded asshole azad gets the best of
him just before security gets the best
of Zod this calls for a hans zimmer Blom
does anyone else look at that sound yet
I swear if Hans Zimmer did the music -
you're a Good Man Charlie Brown if he
your good man charlie
so that is sentenced to imprisonment in
the Phantom Zone you believe your son is
safe I will find him sorry didn't quite
catch that I would find him
no still didn't get it I will find him
mmm still not coming through tell you
what say it is loud and ridiculously
hammies your cartoonishly large eyes and
mouth will allow oh now I hear you know
you walk by I get it look at it so they
wait for the inevitable as it's the end
of the world as they know it and
everyone feels blandly fine lady Laura
shouldn't you find refuge what I can't
hear you over the incredibly quiet
destruction of the world there is no
refuge kiddo
so kal-el travels to the plant known as
Earth where he lands on an episode of
Deadliest Catch you okay we may have
skip forward atashi but at least now we
have time to give Clark played by Henry
Cavill some proper development for his
character or just blow shit up again
because the past 20 minutes clearly
haven't shown enough of it
om we unite is Wolverine brawny man
follow my non flammable hands to freedom
when Kansas became oh we're in this kind
of story what kind of story the out of
order story that got critical acclaim
with mementos on Dolan's been trying to
use it with every film he's been
attached to he's a boy
he's a man he's a teenager he's a boy
again he's a man and it wouldn't be so
bad if you would at least talk about
what he's going through but he never
does wait aren't you the one saying that
Nolan films already have too much
dialogue already what kind of sort of
maybe it depends on how you use it I
mean if it's neither use it if it's not
don't well you actually don't need it
here scenes like Clark as a boy getting
used to his powers are already emotional
scenes you don't have to explain them
now that's true scenes like this are
good on their own but we're getting
background on a guy whose personality
were never given time to know look at
this we have a flashback to his
childhood and then we come back to
present time then literally one minute
later we get another flashback to his
childhood welcome back
missed ya they never give any time to
understand this guy I've got to know the
personality of my Minute Rice more than
I have this person so what's wrong with
that
lots of us constantly get flashbacks out
of nowhere about the troubling childhood
Joe what's that papa no I don't want to
wear the big lobster costume why do you
make me wear that anyways no but but no
nothing nipple Tasers please I think the
less I know about this the better
so after countless moments of intense
scenes and harsh action
what is this flashback in the show some
intense scenes and hardac Wow this
Bill's running the gamut of all two
things that can be done with a movie so
young Clark saves the bus of kids which
leads to the dismay of his father John
Kent played by that voice box that
sounds like Kevin Costner or maybe it's
just Kevin Costner they're pretty easy
to mix up we talked about this you have
Clark have to keep this side of yourself
a secret and this of course gives way to
one the most controversial parts of the
movie John can saying he should have let
the kids on the bus die what was I
supposed to do just let him die
maybe yeah
what do you guys say about that show Joe
no but nothing that Joe glycerine Joe oh
sorry
the scene where John Kant says drown the
bastards hey hey
he doesn't say let them die he says
maybe let them die that's much better
well it's his way of saying he doesn't
know and that's what's so great about it
because it mimics real life far more
than previous Superman films it shows
that people don't always have the
answers all he knows is that he doesn't
want his son to be discovered and hurt
but he never says let them die he says
he doesn't know okay fine tough
confusing world
why can't Superman's father then talk to
him like a father what do you mean he's
the one that builds a mom and that's it
every line in this movies just talking
about what a messiah he is you were sent
here for a reason the world finds out
what you can do it's gonna change
everything you're not just anyone Clark
you're the answer to are we alone in the
universe stand proud in front of the
human race he's less of a tough father
and more like a stereotypical Jewish
mother oh you gotta see my son when the
world finds out what he can do it's
gonna change everything he was sent here
for a reason he's the answer to are we
alone in the universe ma'am nine-one-one
is for emergencies only oh sorry I could
have had a busload of drowned kids for
you but my son saved them too but don't
worry I punished him properly for that
ma'am
never pick up the phone why does
everyone keep telling me that come on
those are some strong well-written words
it's every point destiny monologue we've
heard before oh yeah prove it people are
afraid of what they don't understand you
always fear what you don't understand
people fear but they don't understand
people fear what they do
understand who are frightened by what
they don't understand he said it
differently though we found in this this
was in the chamber with you I took her
to a metallurgist at Kansas State he
said whatever it was made from didn't
even exist on the periodic table that's
another way of saying that it's not from
this world Clark they surprisingly ask
no questions and let me take my miracle
stone home without ever calling anybody
see they knew how to keep a secret and
it turns out years later Clark does a
good job carrying that secret like when
a bully inflicts no physical harm on him
whatsoever so he crucify his truck
costing God knows how much money in
damages but at least he didn't save
anybody so seeing how we're watching
Clark go on this long journey are we
finally gonna get some idea of what his
personality is look at you all know the
answer to this hello other characters
and subplots one of them being Lois Lane
played by Amy Adams doing a report on
some sort of disturbance hell no you
cannot badmouth Lois Lane she's a
stronger character a more confident one
she's a risk-taker she doesn't have time
for the military's pissing contest she
actually does something in this film and
she's not only screaming for someone to
save her yeah that is until she is hit
by the Nolan Wray the what the Nolan
Rhea you see I have no doubt that Zack
Snyder started off having Lois as an
interesting funny opinionated character
because at first she does seem that way
we're done measuring dicks can you have
your people show me what you found but
then she's at by the Nolan Wray and
suddenly every line of dialogue is
emphasizing the weight of how important
the movie you're watching is remember
when his father was balling him out like
a real father right we talked about this
you have no one right you're the answer
to are we alone in the universe
remember how Lois Lane was feisty in
took no nonsense from anybody well what
can I say
writer flops I'm not wearing a flak
jacket boom no libray the questions
raised by my rescuers existence are
frightening to contemplate even Barry
White played by Laurence Fishburne he
starts off in your face screaming about
stories and deadlines you let Woodburn
just shotgun it all over the Internet no
let's make it three weeks that you're so
willing to agree with me no that's way
too winter ethic a little bit of a
building right we'll fix that can you
imagine how people on this planet would
react if they knew there was someone
like this out there then Nolan rain
because whatever important issue you're
talking about it always be more
important critic you know sometimes life
is like that life can be tough life can
be cruel life can throw lobster costumes
and nipple teasers into reality then I
ever gotta know the story to that the
less you know the better so Lois follows
a certain laser eyeing someone into the
ice where she discovers a spaceship a
spaceship that apparently saw her
performance and Julie and Julia but
Clark is there to take down the machine
he or her wounds and apparently leave
her for dead when she observes that
Clark has taken the spaceship away she
tries to write a report on it only to
find her boss won't run it so she lets
it leaked to the Internet my editor
won't print it but if it happened to
leak online but didn't you once describe
my site as a creeping cancer of
falsehoods
hey look it's TMZ how's it going hey
they're the scum of the earth so Clark
loads the exposition program and through
some pretty awesome effects a computer
with what's left of jor-el explains
Krypton's history
that's my name and I'm Joe bear I'll
race spread out through the stars the
scalp ship was one of thousands launched
into the void we sent thousands of these
Scout ships and yet our backup plan in
case the world blows up was a little
baby sized pod you can see why we didn't
last very long
artificial population control was
established so let's explain that Clark
is Krypton's first natural birth in
centuries not exactly sure how they
control that weather everyone just kept
to the honor system or if they
genetically altered babies to be born
with chastity belts but regardless Clark
has apparently broken the chain and he
now knows it's his job to do what he can
for all mankind so he practices flying
around the mountainside well the
cameraman practices keeping his finger
off the goddamn zoom button yeah
you may notice very quickly there's a
lot of this in this movie for no reason
at all whenever there's fast paced
motion the camera has to zoom in on it
like a monkey with a fucking camcorder
how do you think the cinematographer
came across that ingenious move yo come
on honey give daddy the camera no no I
have to show mr. Sneijder my test for
the Man of Steel please no come on I can
explain I love this I knew you would so
let's go searching for her rescuer slash
lever of people to die in the snow and
through asking questions and listening
to hearsay she locates exactly where he
is
of course this calls for celebrating
with another flashback tired
I just want to do something useful with
my life so farming feeding people that's
not that's not use a family's been
farming for five generations but wait a
minute papa kehte did you just in a few
flashbacks say that he was destined to
change the world when people discovered
him the world finds out what you can do
it's gonna change everything
and now you're saying you never wanted
to be discovered and you just want him
to be a farmer I'm starting to think
like as three fathers jerel John and
Jones all their freaking personality but
get ready for a big shot here something
big and terrible tries to kill them and
thus they all try the seek shelter I'll
get him no no get your mom to be over
balls but wait a minute
we'll be saved by John even though it
would have been a lot easier if he just
sent Clark in to go get and causing John
to hurt his leg unable to make it back
in time but he stops Clark from saving
him because he's an attention hungry
Marvin who doesn't want Clark to be
outed even though he's gonna be out of
just a few years later anyway wait what
yep even though there's about a million
other ways this problem could have been
solved John Kent sacrifices himself
because he stands by how Clark should
change the world by never doing a
goddamn thing
he's just doing what he thinks is right
but it's not right but he thinks it's
right does that make it right does that
make it not right not right right right
right right what the hell do we just
agree on you see this movie's deeper
than you think it's raising questions
I'll shut up while we're at it why does
everyone in this movie take death like a
light breeze all the people who die in
this film never flinch move or even make
a noise and these does have range from
stabbing explosion and tornado
I think somebody in that lineup would at
least go out maybe well the movies tired
of waiting for Clark to actually do
anything so General Zod appears on the
monarch ship to threaten the world to
hand him over think whoever's at the
helm of that thing is
can make a dramatic entrance thanks for
the arrow by the way we never won't know
what we were supposed to look at you
know my name is General Zod I come from
a world far from your so it looks like
their ability to take over all of Earth
video footage understandably gives a
barely visible picture but for some
reason that sound sure seems crystal
clear to kal-el I say this surrender
within 24 hours
oh and tell Nash thanks for the
microphone it works great
no problem tyrannical overlord watch
this world suffer the consequences
Socrates pitted Orson Welles ladies and
gentlemen to assure you that the War of
the world has no further significance
and at the Holiday offering it was
intended to be so Clark tries to figure
out what to do and seeks the advice of
both his mother and possibly a higher
source what is that I don't know where
to start
rebby you want I can't make that out
what is that do you know why they were
she's off so clerk reveals himself and
surrenders to the military who have also
brought in Lois seeing how she's the
only one who knew anything about his
existence what's the S stand for it's
not an S on my world it means hope
well here it's an S oh I could look at
your ass all day really hey you done
worse I am
teenies is is and titties is titties is
a iesson kitty so he convinces humanity
that he's not a threat and a he's going
to hand himself over to Zod humanity
goes okay and let him turn himself in to
Zod second-in-command
Faora but she also seems to what Lois to
go with to General Zod would like this
woman to accompany me sorry
I'll go we also got Julie and Julie on
planet Krypton you will pay for costing
Meryl Streep and Oscar as if she doesn't
have enough shut up so they go aboard
Zod ship but Clark has a hard time
adapting to their atmosphere he's
rejecting our ships atmospherics hello
welcome to my weird mantle thingy I and
my fellow officers was sentenced to the
Phantom Zone
so that explains how they were freed
once Krypton was destroyed and how they
got the ship working to travel to earth
to find him I well yes we remember he
explains that the Codex for all living
things on Krypton is in his possession
and so he has the power to make Krypton
live again Krypton lives again
what happens to earth the foundation has
to be built on something
you know is it really wise to tell your
only hope for the future of your race
that you're going to destroy his place
that he calls home when they kind of
make him resistant and thus make things
go a little slower maybe this wasn't
what he was supposed to see
maybe they accidentally put in the wrong
program to show up if I give you the
Codex what happens to her the foundation
has to be built on something no no no no
no no no skulls skulls everywhere look
does that you get this isn't going to
make him happy little turn you into a
raving psychotic when the happy program
the happy program see much better well
we've got dancing bunnies here and oh
look at the flowers all smiling oh
there's even a unicorn riding a
marshmallow rainbow isn't that adorable
you'll stay here until we remember the
incredibly important reason we brought
you on board this gives her a chance to
use jor-el in a box as they plain what I
have to admit is a pretty awesome escape
thanks to you I'm uploading to the
ship's mainframe
- you're right Wow I do oh my god
I want this guy's an AI on my next
first-person shooter game
secure yourself inside the open part
safe travels miss lane
this also allows Clark to escape as he's
set to go down to earth and stop them
from harming anybody we wanted you to
learn what it meant to be human first so
the one day when the time was right you
could be the bridge between two peoples
you can save all of them but my father
said never to be noticed or help people
follows at Walt who directed the post
menu he'll go oh oh we heard you the
first time hey what's wrong with a
little savior symbolism here they're
here or there I don't think the Bible
has as much Jesus imagery okay okay but
what would someone who's half a mortal
and half human be like would it be more
human or would it be more godlike yes he
floats away on a cross but but to me
they're just trying to have a move
graceful in space okay they're not
literally saying he's Jesus or God and
the church scene supports that he's
humble he's more human than we know he
needs the advice of others to help him
make the right decision and this is when
he truly comes over to our side becomes
one of us you know what forget it let's
just say you win really yeah I'll claim
assistant canis almost I don't want to
watch any more of this dark
unpleasantness probably please happy
angry fanboys to a rad
score one for angry Joe I'm gonna
convince you yet you know how come on
show is so easy to hack
I come from a world far from you I
travel over the ocean of stars two-week
hold on a second
but how do we still have dial-up this is
General Zod I've been watching your
little review and I'm displeased to
discover that you were giving it a
positive rating yeah he loves it now
it's like one of his favorite movies
shut up Joe perhaps you're unaware of
how many people watch you nostalgia
critic and how much I personally despise
the film you are currently reviewing and
how easy would be for me to rearrange
your testicles so that they look like
Jackson Pollock droppings and joke's on
you Zod
once the critic makes up his mind
nothing changes it Joe you can literally
rip his intestines out with a nut in
beale air Joe you can suck out his eyes
with a vacuum pull Joe but you could put
him in a lobster costume and hang them
upside down okay two ferrets injected
with bad mojo surprisingly this isn't
helping looks odd hold on I'm writing
that last one down is odd the review
isn't done yet I'm gonna watch it all
the way through whoo very good and if
you don't hate it I will make sure that
the course they find of you they will
never recognize as a corpse hey that's
not fair
critic if you go back on your opinion
you're not the whole of the internet
hounding you down like an animal
can we all just hate Superman for
you
so Clark or as some people are calling
it now Superman gets Lois out of the
escape pod before it explodes oh what a
charming romantic ma no time for that
here we got exposition dispute I didn't
want to tell him anything about you but
they did something to me they looked
inside my mind jacket put it the same
thing to me
huh guess they forgot to show that scene
kind of pointless seeing how they could
get the exact same information out of
him
hell maybe Zod managed to find the
correct imagery this time you see miss
lane all of this and more can be yours
if you just give us the information we
require even the unicorn riding a
marshmallow rainbow even the unicorn
riding the marshmallow so that
approaches Clark's mother dressed as
that thing from the opening of alien and
tries to force her to tell him where the
Codex is the Codex is not here where has
he hidden it no where is the product
does this guy have any charm outside of
just shouting his ass off help us God
get this position anyway go down to
Shogun Superman saves his mother but
potentially dooms this entire town by
bringing the battle to them it seems
okay for the moment as Zod can adapt to
Earth's atmosphere but miss not Ursa and
her masked minions can make up for that
I'm sorry sir the red white and boom
pancakes are at Denny's I appreciate
your enthusiasm Bo and as many people
have pointed out the product placements
in this scene are beyond horrendous
including some painful plugs for I hop
Sears 7-eleven u-haul there's so many
ads clashing in the scene I don't think
they could properly plug them all in
time when in town get a healthy dose of
pancakes from IHOP but wait when you
need a little pick-me-up
grab a slushie from 7-eleven I mean when
you're looking for clothes for any
occasion Sears us a place where you
thought moving soon let you all handle
all of your services oh now you're not
even trying all right all right I'll
give you that one there is way too much
of that in the film but critic you have
to admit the action steam is still
amazing what with countless plugs and
people dying left and right
come on you know your inner manchild
can't look past how amazingly awesome
the wanton destruction is
damn my testosterone of course it's
fucking awesome lingo right all the
guests let's see wasting the ban and he
throws it out there but you know hello
and then she got a hip a guide injectors
a new shoe but the Superman when you
bomb and I catches him in the round
they're like going over it's like Dragon
Ball Z is that's all the shitty stuff
and cut out well something is just not
Dragon Ball Z shitty stuff do shitty
stuff but this stuff is awesome
pardon me but what's our hearing
enjoyment of this picture uh no sir
guren pussy no that's what I'm going to
be if I piss him off he finally gets
their helmets offs drain seeing how the
odds came off in one explosion there's
took like a bajillion and seeing how
he's won he goes back to his mother to
see if she's alright
nice suit son she's sorry it's only
static Clark
oh good could you tell the people down
the street that Moulton my ass and
property damages but Zod discovers the
Codex is in Superman's bloodstream and
that he doesn't need to be alive in
order for them to get it so it's time to
do a little planet redecorating
ladies and gentlemen because you've
never seen the destruction of a major
city in a summer blockbuster before we
give you nothing we just said oh my god
we'll get all the places they're
destroyed including I hop daddy's Toys R
Us tears all the ingeniously marketed
humanity's so two machines on either
side of the world start leveling the
planet
this calls for Star Trek style mumbo
jumbo mixed in with a simple analogy the
audience can understand ship a star by
something called a phantom drive it
bends space Zod ship uses the same
technology and if we can make the two
drives collide with one another a
singularity can be created like a black
hole like putting too much air in a
balloon
of course it's so simple so the army
goes to take out the one in the city
while Superman goes to take out the one
over the Indian Ocean now I know there's
a lot of people who get angry saying
Superman should have taken the one in
the city first no it's not just Superman
who saves the world with one direct
method brave civilians are military and
Superman working together as one only he
can make it there that fast to the other
side of the world and only he could
possibly get around its defenses Joe
honestly this setup is so confusing I'll
just take your word for it no everybody
goes nuts over this so I'm gonna explain
it what if Superman went for the main
one and then they went for the other one
there they may not be able to shut the
other one down maybe the other one has a
self-destruct mechanism which would blow
up the entire earth if the first one got
blown up so that adapts to the Earth's
atmosphere apparently half a lifetime
again used to this can be reduced down
to a couple seconds now and grabs the
scoutship in order to start rebuilding
Krypton meanwhile Lois is on board the
military ship about to blast the other
one to hell when something seems to go
wrong
what's it supposed to do damn it Louis
you had one job that we pointlessly put
you in charge of and that was just to
push a button and you couldn't even do
that right they do eventually get it to
work but Zod is hot on their trail
target that aircraft terminate with
extreme disinterest but Superman stop
the machine over the Indian Ocean and
flies back to destroy Zod on his ship if
you destroy this ship you destroy
Crypton had its chance the bridge
between two worlds everybody if you have
a chance to save a civilization but yeah
they were kind of jerks just destroy any
chance of them ever coming back
I guess the bridge in this movie is code
for either us or them and honestly even
us kind of got the raw end of it
are they gone I think so they saved us
Oh for god sake could you say that in a
part of the city that doesn't look quite
so 911 for crying out loud
oh that's missing his Bush in a banner
that says mission accomplished
even they say it's all downhill after
the first kiss who the hell says that
but it turns out Zod is still alive n
angry that his future has been reduced
to hot chocolate mix I exist only to
protect Krypton and every action I take
no matter how violent or how cool
is for the greater good those odd vows
to destroy Superman to any cost
logically seeing how he'll chase
Superman anywhere
Superman leads him to a location far
away from the people so that none of
them will ever get hurt or he once again
brings the most dangerous thing in the
world to the people he swore to protect
yeah I'm sure they're really thankful
thanks for saving us Superman yeah
imagine the real damage it could have
been done if he did come to our planet
oh look side o Jesus is gonna save us
again wait it go Superman putting us up
club all us again
Superman gets him in a headlock but Zod
vows to make what he supposedly cares
for most suffer to us even though
there's about three or four different
ways those people could probably get out
of there
you have to admit soup this isn't all
made these people are just kind of
idiots never
plus we get our biggest controversial
moment in all of the movie Superman
breaks
Zod's neck really nothing from you on
that one Joe oh and that's how it saved
Christmas with the lightning gone was I
talking about
the controversial neck breaking scene oh
you know I'm not gonna lie when I first
saw that scene I hated it but the more
you really think about it this is a
really bold choice because ultimately
atlet's
sod when it plays again to a young and
inexperienced clark and how he knows his
actions will have huge ramifications yes
because having the city new didn't have
enough ramifications point being it's a
catalyst now for why you will never ever
take another life the fact that he had
to do it to one of his own people one of
the last remaining Kryptonians at that
moment he not only chooses to be human
but he makes the ultimate sacrifice for
Humanity and he also makes himself
forever alone I agree ah I knew you'd
say that
wait what yeah surprisingly the most
hated scene by so many fans actually
didn't bother me that much I mean keep
in mind we saw Superman kills Zod in the
second movie and no one had a heart
attack over that and on top of that even
though it could have been illustrated
better I liked the idea they were going
for that you won't always have answers
to situations that are always epically
pleasing it's actually a very difficult
very hard thing to come to grips with
tonight forgotten in the very next scene
he just blows some more shit up because
like I said we haven't seen enough of
that yeah it's pretty rushed I mean he
takes down a satellite and then they
make a joke about how hot he is and
and they never bring it up again it's
almost like the scene before never
freakin happened it really pisses me the
fuck off it just ruined it right there
they never established that killing
people was a big thing for him hell we
saw so many other civilians die I
figured that he'd be used to seeing it
by now um we never actually see any of
those people die as a direct result from
Superman I mean sure we see people die
when Zod ship is is like humping the
earth but I get what you're saying
you're actually saying we agree on the
neck break then I think so the one part
most fans universally hate we actually
think is okay for the most part yeah so
does that mean you actually like it
critic yes does that mean you actually
like this nostalgia critic
I don't think this movie is awful oh
come on man huh no I'm sorry I just
think it's terrible there are some
things I like all the actors to play
these roles are good choices the action
scenes are awesome and though I like the
more upbeat Superman I'm open to the
idea of the darker version but these
characters have no identity outside of
their job and how they look but you
wouldn't even know that this was Clark
Kent or Lois Lane if they didn't call
them Clark Kent or Lois Lane the
millions of subplots are not needed and
get in the way of any emotional
connection we want to make the
incoherent storytelling is pointless and
annoying and as a superhero
he lets way too many people die in this
even if he took Superman's name off of
this I still win like this stupid
illogical mess I think you're totally
wrong reading everything you just said
those characters seem boring to you
because they're not as over-the-top or
single noted as the comic book ones are
the Christopher Reeves versions it's a
new kind of Superman that needs a less
cliched character okay
it needs a tougher and darker outlook
because we've seen the other Superman
stories already those are still there
and by putting the inglese morally
confusing lessons that you call
illogical I see them as challenging and
there's no way to save every single body
like in previous movies and always get
your way there's just a man struggling
between what it means to be human and
more than human and trying to do the
right thing yet he still manages to rise
above it and save us all this movie is
awesome oh please your host own hands
won't be too much into anything why
don't you say that to my fist hair gel
there could be a great people they wish
to be they only lack the light to show
the way for this reason above all their
capacity for good
I'll sent them you my only son
I think I understand now Joe I will
never like this movie I think it's an
insult to everything Superman stands for
and I will never understand how you
could actually like it oh nice but just
because I can't see how doesn't mean I
can't understand why oh because I'm a
blood hungry psychopath right no I mean
you are but that's not why I think you
like it when I see this movie
I see people dying for the sake of
getting violent craving teens in the
seats but that's not what you see you
see one of your favorite superheroes
being tested and put through a greater
challenge than ever before and by having
him witness and go through so much
intensity it makes his challenges in
greater and his drug 'el all the more
interesting for you and probably a lot
of people that enjoy this movie you're
seeing the Man of Steel go up against
some of the greatest evil aids ever gone
up against because of how much damage he
does so when he rises up you can feel
all the more proud of what a terrible
thing he stopped it's not craving dark
horrible things like a maniac it seems
someone fight against those dark
horrible things and not just through him
holding heavy stuff but by standing up
for what he feels is important I don't
see the same thing but the very least I
know that's what you see so as long as
you're viewing it because you want to
see the best of strength and kindness
rise up against the worst of oppression
and force all I can say is go ahead and
enjoy it map
thanks for understanding little the road
bullshit won't work on me it was done
don't worry great I'll stop them tell me
it's location hey how are you doing that
but better
now prepare for entree or spill orders
and pain Oh for Christ's sake will you
guys stop punching holes in my ceiling
you stop you again sod
stay back Superman well the Craig's
toast careful Zod you know what I can do
oh yeah what are you gonna do kill me
you break my neck you'll have message
boards all over you like an unemployed
writer at Starbucks
so come on big man what are you gonna do
Wow you lasered his balls off yep but at
least I didn't kill him but you laser
his balls off I mean he had it coming
and I'm surprising him to begin with
Jesus well then what'd you do huh you
know the usual made sure they got those
Lois forbid flew into space smile for
the camera
and I bet you were played off to a hot
summer theme come on man no no no no I
swear
they're like exactly the same I mean
here's my theme did it you did it you
did it you did it now here's our theme
did it today it's like a semitone off
hey you know speaking of ripoffs does
this seem at all familiar to you what do
you mean like just this whole set up I
feel like I might have seen this before
oh my god don't look what I said oh look
you look did you yes I did did they see
you I don't think so
are you sure I can check I don't look
hmm they're looking right at us just
keep your eye down on the table hey hey
good man doesn't have a big we don't
hear that we're keeping our eyes down on
the table
you know that
incest or be I'm mentally depressed and
psychologically tortured not special
I've stared into the past and D forward
and have come out scar yet responsibly
strong I reflected when I'm in my giant
dark empty food shelves familiar trying
to save people but under my protection
the civilian death toll is treble
you
I will find him